[Musique]
hop ça dit quoi
hop 81 points 2 vous allez mon poids
pour l'éducation de tous c'est une cata
non c'est les résultats
aïe les résultats quand je peux je
montre aux gens le taux de gras 15% je
suis content j'ai baissé youlou muscles
65% et la dation en 61 densité osseuse 3
3 tout ça est en verre dioum leurs
effets tout à fait autres voilà tout ce
que ça vous donne les voyeurs et de rome
roger une graisse sous cutanée qui est
un petit peu un petit peu trop
importante à neurones ça j'aime bien ta
d'améliorer tout ce que ça vous donne
honnêtement ça c'est le conseil que je
donne ne regardez pas tout tout tout ce
qui vient puisqu'on a vite à faire
pareil et peut-être qu'un jour je dis
bien peut-être pour me ressemblerait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin
risson
des bus c'est qui le plus beau chien
c'est qui le plus beau sur abu dis c'est
qu'il est plus beau chien c'est bien dit
c'est betty qu'est ce que c'est parce
terrain du bruit attendu à mourir - tout
entendu bien avant ce qu'espère des
grosses dettes petit déj ce matin le
festin le festin ce matin prenez soin de
vous je vous embrasse ce qu'apple à la
radio les données de la course a qui
feraient d'accord merci non la merci
pour toute cette force conseils à me
donner travail en voiture et je le sais
ça la suite au prochain épisode
oui ce soir je retrouve mon ami sundy
élevé elle a présenté les ballons dans
le ballon d'or c'est un report
c'est là qu'est ce que vous serez seul
non non non la pression pour les joueurs
je pense mais dans thérèse
[Rires]
[Musique]